good evening it's an intriguing
prospects could the man who created the
world's biggest marketing and
advertising group now set up a rival to
take it on and will there be fresh
impetus to break up WPP following the
shock departure of Sir Martin Sorrell
well this is how WPP shares fur today
they closed down by nearly six and a
half percent well with me now it's
Johnny horn B of the advertising agency
the and partnership Johnny thanks very
much for joining me all for all the
speculation about what happens next to
WPP do you think this business is going
to get broken up I think what's
important now is that the new leadership
make a really good case and I think
there's a great case to be made for why
it should be together and I think you
know clearly Martin's passing as the end
of an era you know he is probably one of
the biggest figures in global in the
history of global media up there with
Rupert Murdoch and you know what he's
built was absolutely astounding and and
you know people will talk quite rightly
for a long time about his talents
equally the construct that he'd created
you can see it in the share price not
just today but over the last you know
year and a bit not just a WP but of all
the holding companies I think is telling
us that it needs to be constructed
differently and the speed with which
data and digital and technology have
come at the advertising industry
requires it to be reconfigured very
differently to the way that it's
configured at the moment now I think the
bit that you could be very optimistic
about if you are a believer in WPP is
that the two people have taken over I
think are in very very well positioned
for those changes Marc Reid is somebody
who has been at Martyn side since the
very beginning but I think crucially has
built all the digital assets within WPP
and digital is at the heart of what the
reconstruction needs to take place
around and Marc Reid came out of the
center working with Martin for the last
couple of years and took over one demand
one of the biggest pieces within WPP and
took that from I think a decline of six
or seven percent a year previously to
five percent year-on-year growth so I
think he's very well positioned I also
think Andrew Scott his other right-hand
man is somebody who knows this business
inside-out and there's been a lot of
speculation that says does martin run
all this from some magical black book
and
you know every asset in that business
Andrew Scott will know and understand so
I think there's a big challenge but I
couldn't think of two better people to
take it on so there they can be the glue
that Sir Martin was in terms of holding
all these disparate businesses together
yes and I think but I think also
crucially they need to take action to
reconfigure those businesses in a very
different way you know I think nowadays
to have the creative people the content
people divorce from the people who are
deploying that content in a world that's
now going very real time is increasingly
looking antiquated in all the holding
companies so they're going to have to
move fast to reconfigure it but they I
think they're two people that know that
and understand the digital world and
will move fast to do that because it's a
really interesting point you raised
there this is a business we had a global
growth at its strongest last year for
the first time since the financial
growth since the financial crisis W
peepees top-line organic revenues didn't
grow during the year I mean come on
earth suggests the business model is no
longer fit for the 21st century the
business model I mean I I passionately
believe that these things need to stay
together so there will be people who
will argue that the media should be sold
off separately all the creatives should
be sold off separately I think actually
the deployment of content needs to be
done hand in glove now with the creative
people almost in a real-time kind of
marketing newsroom environment I think
there are parts of WPP that you could
argue could be spun off you know the
research business to me wouldn't seem
something that is crucial anymore to the
big challenges the WPP faces and those
big challenges I think simply are at the
very top end you've got large
international businesses going through
business transformations trying to put
data at the heart of their organisations
and trying to put reconfigure their
businesses around personalization and
data there's new competitors now for the
holding companies with the likes of
Deloitte Accenture etc so at the top end
you need to reconfigure to make the case
I think and again I think Andrew and
Marc will do this for why the data and
the technology should be in service of
the ideas and the creativity not the
other way around and I think that's
where a WPP could win against against
those big consultants then you've also
got the challenge of the Facebook's and
the googles and you have to very well
make your case here
for why you need an honest transparent
broker on the media side you know as
long as we still have facebook making
claims as they did last year that there
are more teenagers on their platform
than there actually were teenagers in
the whole of the UK then I think there's
a role for somebody to say right we
should be between the brands and these
technology companies as the honest
brokers of media and I think if you can
make those two cases very well and
reconfigure the business then I think
you've got a very good chance of
bringing a background what about the
clients so I mean WP Pease got something
like 2 billion pounds worth of business
that comes up for tender this year yeah
a client's gonna walk
I don't think clients are going to walk
because of a change of leadership
despite the fact that Martin is you know
has been a fantastic leader I think
there is a case to be made that says
this change in this reconfiguration is
needed to happen for a couple of years I
mean personally I think Martin still had
the energy and the intellect and the
capability to have brought about that
you know brought about that change but
that change is now going to hand over to
to somebody else so I think those
clients won't walk if Mark and Andrew
are able to reconfigure these businesses
in a way that's incredibly relevant to
them and you know people of course have
personal relationships but business is
business dishes and decisions around
billion-pound
marketing campaigns will actually come
down to who has the best capabilities
and I think reconfigured at WPP is still
you know the man United of holding
companies it just needs to get its mojo
back go beefy Johnny you were named in
the weekend press as a possible
successor to Sir Martin do you have any
ambitions in that field no I think my
businesses is going along very nicely as
it is Ian and I and I have huge faith in
in in Andrew and and and Mark to do a
great job with it all right Johnny
who'll be great to see us ever thanks
for coming on